FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 26 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
I'm very happy, and very
excited about interview
to Gustavo Ambrosio.
MARK MANDEL: Gustavo
Ambrosio from Pocket Gems
is here today to talk
to us about their game
War Dragon, and how their
backend of the structure works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I love to talk that you gave
with him, [INAUDIBLE] next.
I thought it was a very
interesting thought,
because there was a lot of
interesting technical aspects,
and also a bunch of dragons.
So that's always good.
MARK MANDEL: Whenever there's
dragons, that's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And he's back to basically
tell us a little bit more
about all the details, and all
the things behind the scenes
on what is the name?
War of dragons?
MARK MANDEL: War Dragons.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: War Dragons.
War of Dragons is a worse name.
I like War Dragons.
MARK MANDEL: War dragons.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And after that, we're going
to be talking about Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we have
a nice follow up question
from one of our listeners.
Heron, who is one of our,
I think, more prolific
commenters on the podcast.
I challenge anyone to beat
him for number of comments.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should send him a t-shirt.
We still have not done it yet.
MARK MANDEL: He's been
on the podcast, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
He deserves a
t-shirt, maybe two.
But before that,
we're going to be
talking about the cool
thing of the week, as often.
And it's actually a very
interesting cool thing
of the week.
And it seems ,net was open
sourced some time ago.
This effort has now
been doable, which is,
you can now run .net
applications on Google Club
platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is pretty cool.
I know some people
would be like, but wait,
couldn't I have just spun
up a Windows instance before
and done this myself regardless?
But I think the cool thing
is we've got now .net client
libraries for connecting to
things like Cloud Datastore
and other services that we have.
So you want to not just run
just regular old applications,
but you want to interact
with some of the managed
services we have, I think that's
a really, really cool offering.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's a blog post, and
we'll put a link to it
on the show notes.
But basically, the important
thing that I think is very
exciting is the fact that if you
like writing .net applications
and you really
know how to do it,
now you can still do it and use
some of the infrastructure that
Google Cloud Platform offers.
So one of them is
Google Cloud Datastore,
we talked about many times.
So basically, this
way of basically
storing data that scales
is completely managed,
so you don't have
to care about it.
There's a bunch of examples.
There's a Hello World tutorial,
there's a bookshelf tutorial.
But basically, give
it a try and let us
know what you think about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that'd be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so I guess it's time
to go and talk to Ambrozio.
I keep on changing his name.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
that's his last name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so Mr. Ambrozio.
Gustavo.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, let's
go chat with Gustavo.
Thanks so much to Gustavo
Ambrosio joining us today.
Lead software engineer at Pocket
Gems, and one of the genius
brains behind War Dragons.
How are you doing today?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Well I'm doing
better now that I'm a genius.
I didn't know that.
But thank you.
Thank you for that,
thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: More than happy
to give compliments like that.
So thanks so much for
coming to talk to us today
about Pocket Gems, about War
Dragons, about the game itself.
But why don't you
tell us a little bit
about who you are, what you do
all that sort of good stuff.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: So
I'm a software engineer,
I've been a software engineer
for I don't know how long.
I started when I was 15,
even before college I started
programming, and today I'm
42 so you do the math there
I don't think I've ever done
anything else in my life.
I love it.
And mostly I've worked in Brazil
on non-gaming related stuff.
Some boring corporate stuff.
And then at some
point, I started
coming here to San
Francisco a lot,
And I just wanted to move here.
I was like, this
is my place, this
is where software
engineers have to come.
It's kind of like the--
MARK MANDEL: The mecca?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
The mecca, yeah.
So I decided to come here, so
I started looking for a job,
and I found Pocket Gems.
They interviewed me, they
hired me, they gave me a visa.
So I moved, and
I've been working
there for the last
3 and 1/2 years
making games, and having
fun, and creating stuff.
It's awesome, I love it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So I know that you've
been behind a game
called War Dragons, which has
had some pretty decent success.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yes, we did.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Do you want to tell
us a little bit
about the game, what it's about,
what's the style of the game?
All that sort of fun stuff.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
OK, so the game,
War Dragons is a highly
polished, 3D real time strategy
mobile game where you collect
and control hundreds of dragons
to take out enemy bases.
In short, you get to control a
lot of awesome looking dragons
and blow up a lot of stuff.
It was Pocket
Gem's first 3D game
with a real time synchronous
multiplayer battles,
and our first game to come
out with social features
from day one.
Features like chat, guilds,
forums, leaderboards,
all of that.
That's the first game that
on day one we had that.
Development-wise it was
our longest game from start
to release.
We never had a game that
had that size before.
had the size of the team
that we have right now.
So it was a great
learning experience for us
at Pocket Gems.
We had to create
a new 3D engine,
we had to create a lot of
real time communication stuff
or for mobile.
It was a really exciting
project to work on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I wanted to add also
since you just showed us
that on top of having
so many cool features,
you also have a very cool ad,
and I thought it was amazing.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Thank you, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I would
put that on the show.
It is super cute and
creepy at the same time.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
We're trying to reach
an audience of like,
this is supposed to show on
like Comedy Central, and ESPN.
So you imagine you are like
a person, like 30 years old,
and you're watching ESPN, and
that thing comes on, it's like,
it's kind of weird,
you have to watch it.
You understand what I'm saying?
But it's probably going to get
your attention a little bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We'll put it on the show
notes, that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: It's
definitely worth watching.
It's hilarious.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Really made me laugh.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: We
like it, we like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you said it's
an Android game,
and I'm interested on the
Android side of it too.
But could you
explain a little bit
about since it's an
Android game, what
is the part on the Cloud?
Like, why are you using
the Cloud, and how?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: So
it's on Android and iOS.
We started with iOS, we just
released our Android version
roughly a month ago.
And the Cloud
basically allows us
to-- we need the Cloud to
do all the social features.
We need to cloud, because it's
a game where everybody's bases
matter, and everything.
Like you can affect the
game of other players.
It's a very connected game.
We need to have
that connectivity.
We need to have all the Cloud
to support those features.
So it's very, very heavily
based on the Cloud.
Like we have a lot of features
that are based on the Cloud.
We like to release new events.
For example, every week
we have special events,
and all of our special
events are heavily
based on Cloud technology.
They're not built on the phone.
We have something very
generic on the phone,
and then we can just push
different events every week
just using our cloud technology.
It also allows us to have
Android and iOS players playing
together at the same time.
So it doesn't matter if
you're playing Android
or if you're playing iOS,
you're going to battle people
within other platforms, as well.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And it also allows you to do
a lot of stuff with analytics
as well, doesn't it?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
We've been doing
analytics on the Cloud
since the beginning
of Pocket Gems.
Like basically, we
always have a lot
of heavy analytics on the
Cloud for all of our games.
So we have already this
built into all of our games.
We have a common platform
that every game sends
all their events,
and all the data
that we need to figure out
what are users enjoying here,
what are users not enjoying?
We use it to do AB testing.
To see if a new feature is
something that the users are
going to like or not.
And then we decide to release
features based on that data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Are you also using analytics
not only for features, but also
to analyze performance,
and stuff like that?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
So one part of the
analytics that we do
is collect performance
from devices.
So we can split by device
type, and by platform,
and we know what
places of the game
are slowing down
the user, or places
that are using too much memory.
So we can also use that data
to drive our development
to make our game perform
faster, have better FPS.
We're always trying to have
very smooth animation, which
is really hard with the range
of devices that we work with.
Like, if you have a
very high end device
it's easy to do that.
But when you go to
the lower end devices
that we still want to support
because still a lot of people
are using those devices, it
becomes really, really hard.
And having all that data to help
us focus on an area of the game
that we need to improve
performance and make
the game smoother for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So obviously you've got a
back end infrastructure.
You're on our podcast,
which probably means you're
using Google Cloud Platform.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yes
MARK MANDEL: Do you want to
tell us a little bit about what
backend infrastructure you're
using, how you're using it,
that sort of stuff?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah, we've
been using Google App Engine
heavily since the
beginning of Pocket Gems.
So from the first game that
when the company was just
two people, the two
founders, they started
using Google App Engine.
And we haven't looked back.
Like, Google App Engine
has worked for us really,
really well, and has continued
to work with every game
that we build.
So use Google App Engine a
lot, we use Datastore a lot.
We use probably every feature
that Google App Engine has
to offer, we are using
in very different ways,
very, we think,
innovative ways that we've
used Google App Engine.
I don't know if
you want to mention
the talk we did at GCP Next.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
So there's that talk.
We talk a lot about that.
We go into some more
technical details,
we have some interesting tricks
that we use at Pocket Gems
to be able to run our games
in a smooth way in the Cloud.
So I think we're also going
to put that on the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So something I'm curious
about, and I always
ask this question
every single time
I see people doing real time.
How are you doing
it on App Engine?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: So the
part about real time,
we're using a company
called PubNub.
So PubNub does a lot of
real time stuff as well.
So because we already had
a partnership with them,
we decided to use
that for real time.
And I don't know what they have
in their backend, to be honest.
But we do some stuff which is
near real time in Google App
Engine.
It has low latency, so you
can do stuff like that.
If you're using it
in a clever way,
like we do a lot of stuff that
requires us to be real time,
like all the battle
reports and know whenever
you're fighting someone you
need to distribute resources.
That's all done using
the Google App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: So you're
essentially doing all your user
data, and your game data,
and your matchmaking,
all that stuff's in App Engine?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
All that part is in App Engine.
Matchmaking, whenever you
need to battle someone,
to figure out who is a good
user for you to battle.
Because we have millions
of users, and some of them
have super strong
bases, and some of them
have super you know weak
bases, because they just
started playing.
So you need to figure that out.
That is all done using
Google App Engine.
We have a leader boards, which
is also very computationally
heavy.
We use that on Google
App Engine, actually
using some code that Google
released as open source
for leaderboards.
So we found that when
we were building our
leaderboard [? tac, ?] and we
said, yeah, let's use that.
So we started using that, and
we modified that a little bit
to suit our needs.
But that's the base
of our leaderboard.
What else is the very
complicated there?
Well, all the game user data.
We do support people playing
in multiple devices, that's
also done through the Cloud.
So whenever you quit your
game, we save all your data
in the Cloud.
And if you load that
game in another device,
we load all that
data from the Cloud
so all that game
state management
is done on Google App Engine.
All our AB testing is done
using Google App Engine.
We can release new
dragons, for example,
without releasing a new
version of the game.
We can do something like that.
And it's all done using
Google App Engine.
Even our asset management is
done using Google App Engine,
and using the Google
frontend cache.
It's really fast for us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm assuming that
when you say Google App
Engine to store data, you're
actually using the Datastore?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
For the files, I'm
not sure how we're doing that.
I'm not sure if it's
Google Datastore.
I think it is actually
using Google Datastore.
MARK MANDEL: Could be
Cloud Storage maybe.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
I'm not sure.
That part I don't know.
That part is really-- we
built that in the beginning.
I never had to touch that code.
This has been working for us
for like six years, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It just works.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah, it's
just been working forever.
MARK MANDEL: That is good.
So obviously you've
had some success.
How have you had to change how
your application has been built
since it's been running on App
Engine, running on Datastore.
Have you needed to make
many changes to it,
as the scale of how many
loads, and how many players,
and how many games and
battles have grown?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: No.
At least since I started
working with Pocket Gems,
this has been
working wonderfully.
We never had to worry
about our servers
going down and all of that.
Things just work.
When we released War Dragons,
we had like big spikes that it's
shown in that presentation, you
can see the big spikes that we
had in number of
battles, I think,
is the graph that I had there.
And we didn't have
to touch anything.
We didn't have to
call Google and say,
hey, we're going to
have a big spike here,
so you guys better be ready.
It works, and it scales up and
scales down as you need it,
and things just work.
We had a few adjustments
that we did basically
to control the costs that we
have in Google App Engine.
So there is some stuff
that we were doing,
and the way that we designed
it, it was using too much data,
or it was doing too
many Datastore calls.
So we redesigned the few of
those things to do less calls
and still have the
same functionality
to drive our costs down.
MARK MANDEL: I believe
you're using memcache a lot
to do that, right?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: We
use memcache to do that.
It's also in the presentation.
If people want some
detail on how we do that,
it's a very clever way to
use Memcache, and Datastore,
and Task Use.
So we use all that
technology, and we
were able to drive
our cost down a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
I'm also really curious, I
mean, you just released Android,
you've had an iOS version
out for a long time.
Did you have to
change the App Engine
code at all for each
individual platform,
for your mobile platform?
Or was it the same?
Or what happened there?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Not at all.
It doesn't change anything.
You can imagine we have
a bunch of client code
that we say, if is
Android, do this.
If it's iOS, do this.
But on our platform side, on
the Google App Engine side,
I don't believe we
have any of that.
All the communication is
done completely the same.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Could you tell us it a bit
about how you're doing it?
Is it a REST API?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
It's mostly REST API.
It's really easy to build
REST APIs on top of Google App
Engine, so we mostly use RESTful
APIs with a few exceptions
there, for example, just
to get files is not REST,
it's just plain old HTTP.
There's not a lot of
stuff going on there.
But for all the
data communication,
it's all doing REST, and
with JSON as the format
that we send back and forth.
And it's really easy to use
on the mobile side as well.
There's millions and thousands
of libraries out there
that's going to do that for
you right out of the box
without using anything crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
question that I always ask, too,
for people that write
code on App Engine,
are you writing it in Go?
Is it written in Go?
What is the language
that you use?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: We use Python.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Python, cool.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Yeah, we use Python.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's fine, it's fine.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: No,
Python is awesome.
I love Python.
I haven't written
anything in Go,
so I'm not going to badmouth it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Excellent.
So you do some really
interesting things.
We covered this in
our presentation,
but I'd like to
go over it again,
because I think it
was really clever.
How you use App Engine
versions, and match those up
to client versions.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about how that works?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure.
So Google App Engine versions,
for people that don't know,
it's basically, you can deploy
various versions of your code
in Google App Engine,
then Google App Engine's
going to give you a different
URL for every version
that you have.
Traditionally, this
is used for testing.
So if I'm a developer and
I'm developing a new feature,
I don't want to keep
deploying that to production.
So we deploy that to a different
version of Google App Engine,
and then I can test that
using that different URL,
without disturbing
production code.
But at Pocket Gems, we devised
a different use for that.
So whenever we release a new
version on mobile, what happens
is sometimes we have
to break compatibility
with the previous version
of Google App Engine.
And traditionally, people have
been doing that with if else,
if else, if version
is this, do this.
If version is that, do that.
And then you end up
with a lot of code that
is old code, and awful to read.
So we don't like that.
So what we do is, we
basically, whenever
we release a new version
of Google App Engine,
we don't care about
breaking compatibility.
And what we do is
when we release
a new version of
the game, we first
deploy the new version we
deploy in a different URL,
and we configure our client
code to go to that URL instead.
So then when people start
downloading that new version,
they go to the new version
of Google App Engine.
And the old version still
go to the old version,
so we don't break
compatibility there.
It all works for everyone.
And then at some
point, what we do
is we force users to upgrade.
So a few days after
we release something,
we force users to upgrade.
Then everybody
upgrades, and we were
able to take down
the old version.
And now the new
version becomes what
is called the default
version, and everybody just
connects to that version.
So we're able to very
easily break compatibility
without actually
breaking anything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
I guess that that's the power
of being able to force clients
to be updated.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah,
we didn't have to do that.
We only do that because
also we sometimes break
compatibility in battle.
So when you're battling people
online with the new version
might have a different
spell that we created.
And then if I'm fighting you
when you have the old version,
and I do that
spell, that spell's
not going to work on your end.
So now things
become out of sync.
So we break
compatibility basically
not because of server code.
Like, if you think
about server code,
we could just keep 10
versions running there.
It wouldn't cost us much, or
anything else, I think, more,
and it wouldn't be
such a big deal.
But there's this
client part that
does break compatibility
when people
are playing with each other
online that would break.
So that's why we force
people to upgrade, basically.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is interesting.
Otherwise, people could
use the strategy of,
I'm not going to upgrade,
so no one can attack me.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
But then you can't
attack anyone, and yeah.
You lose a lot if
you don't do that.
And the social aspect
of the game, I think,
it's one of the most
important parts.
We've been seeing that
that social aspect of it
is what drives people back.
Like we have guilds, too, so
everybody is part of a guild,
and your guild
just plays together
to fight all other guilds,
and your guild members
can help you, and you
attack with their dragons.
So that aspect is really
important for everyone.
So you can see people, whenever
we release a new version,
I get a message from
my guild leader saying,
hey, you should
upgrade your game,
because otherwise
we can't help you.
So upgrade right now so we
can all still help each other.
So that aspect is really nice.
So upgrading is important
for users, not just for us.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So we also covered this
in the presentation,
but again, I thought this
was really interesting.
You used Datastore in some
really interesting ways
to do matchmaking.
Go on and talk a little
bit how that process works.
I know you also use task queues
and some other fun stuff.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
So for matchmaking, it's
kind of a complicated thing
because what I said before.
You have millions of
users, and every user's
going to have a different level.
So what we created,
basically we created
a concept of bucketing users
into similar matchmaking
levels.
So whenever you
do something that
changes what your power
would be, like for example,
you upgraded a building,
or you upgraded a dragon,
or you just applied
some different
what we call runes to
a dragon, for example,
your powers change there.
You become more powerful.
And whenever something
like that happens,
we put a task in the task
queue to basically recalculate
what bucket you should be in.
And then at some point,
that task queue runs,
we will recalculate
your power, and we
see in what bucket is
better for you to be.
And then we place
you in that bucket.
That bucket now is
something that whenever
you want to battle someone,
we just go to that bucket
and we pick some player
that's in that bucket.
We know that they're going
to have a very similar level
to you, so the battle is
going to be challenging.
It's not going to
be something that's
going to be super
easy for you to beat,
or it's going to be
impossible for you to beat.
We know that it's
possible to beat,
you're going to lose some,
you're going to win some.
But it's possible.
But with millions of users,
we couldn't find a better way
to do that and
still perform well.
Because whenever
you battle, that's
one of the most
important things.
We need to respond really fast.
We want you to go into
battle as fast as we can.
So if we have to
wait for the server
to come back with something,
and that takes five seconds,
it's gone.
Like your user's already out
of the game by that point.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So you're able to
leverage task used
to be able to push that
into the background
so that the user doesn't
have to wait for it,
and we can keep that
complicated data processing
happening in the background.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
And it's not that important you
change your bucket right then,
right?
You can wait a few seconds.
Your previous bucket
is still competitive,
it's still very similar
to what you are.
You're not going
to be super easy.
So if it takes five, 10
seconds to change your bucket,
it's not a big deal.
So we just pushed that
to the task queue,
and the task queue does
that calculation for us
in the background.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I think that we're
actually running out of time.
But as always, we'd like to give
you opportunity of telling us
whatever you feel
like we left out.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: I just want to
say that we're hiring engineers
right now, especially we're
looking for managers and leads.
It's a hard position to fill.
So take a look at
our website, we're
going to have that in the
notes, I believe, as well.
Take a look there.
And if you're interested,
just contact me,
it's gustavo@pocketgems.com.
If you're around for
Google I/O, if you
want to come and
visit the office
and just shoot me
an email, you can
come we're here in the
city, pretty close to where
the conference is going to be.
MARK MANDEL: I've been
up to the offices,
the offices are very nice.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
We have a very nice office.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have
not been invited yet.
Just saying.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: You're
officially invited now.
Whenever you want to come.
So we have that position open.
I'm going to be at WWGC.
If you're here for WWGC,
just look me up as well.
We can chat.
We're happy to have you in the
office and show you around.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time today to come
to the office and talk to us.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Thanks for having me.
Your office is also
really awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
very much Gustavo for such
a great interview.
I learned a lot, and I saw a
lot of dragons on the video.
You should definitely
check it out again.
That ad is very, very funny.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But we are almost
about to finish the
episode, but we will not
finish before the
question of the week.
And the question of
the week, as we said,
it's coming from Heron Patel.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
he messaged us
after listening to our episode,
and was quite interesting
in Go, but hadn't
played with it.
He comes from a
Python background,
was immediately curious
about web frameworks in Go.
It's a common question,
I've heard it definitely
a few times before.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
actually a very interesting
question, because especially
for people coming from Python,
and even more coming
from Ruby, they
tend to miss these frameworks.
Such as you're coming from Ruby,
you know there's Ruby on Rails.
If you come in from
Python, there's Django.
If you're writing Go, what's up?
So actually my advice on
this is the first thing
to understand is actually
the difference between what
a framework and a toolkit is.
And while in many
languages you're
going to be finding frameworks--
such as Ruby on Rails
is clearly a
framework-- frameworks
will force you to adapt
your code to whatever they
feel the code should look like.
So that is something
that if that
is what you're trying to
follow, that totally fine.
And if your use case matches
what they're providing,
then it's great.
Now, when you try to modify
it, might be really hard.
So instead, what the
Go community tries
to drive towards is toolkits.
So you have a bunch of toolkits.
You have things like my
favorite one is Gorilla.
MARK MANDEL: Love gorilla.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's a web framework.
It's very, very simple,
and basically you
can pick and choose
whatever you need to use.
So you have like,
oh, I need to use
a different way of
routing requests
toward my web handlers.
There's a way of doing that.
There's I need to do
sessions, or whatever.
There's a bunch of
different tiny packages
that basically you
can add to your code,
and they'll integrate very
well with the standard net HTTP
package.
So that is great.
And if you want to
know more about others,
there's actually
a bunch of them.
We will put a link to a post
from last year from The New
Stack that basically, they
cover five Go frameworks.
And there's Beagle, which
is an actual framework.
There's a Martini, which is a
very lightweight framework that
uses a lot of reflection.
It's kind of like trying
to be Go on Rails,
and it did not work that well.
So the author of the framework,
Jeremy [? Signs-- ?] hi,
Jeremy-- he created
a second version.
It's called Negroni.
It's much simpler, it's
much more lightweight.
So if you think about
using something that's out,
Negroni's also a
very good option.
There is Go Craft, and
then there is also Gorilla.
So check it out,
and also there's
a very good talk from my
friend, I lost the link.
MARK MANDEL: Mark Bates.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: From
my friend Mark Bates.
He used to be a [INAUDIBLE]
and basically he gave a talk
at [INAUDIBLE] two years ago.
And the talk was about, OK
so where is Go on Rails?
And he basically
answers that question.
So the name of the
talk is, everything
you've always wanted to
know about Go webapps
but were afraid to ask.
And of course, we'll have the
link to that on the show notes
here.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it sounds great.
We talked a little
bit about it, but I
think the standard
library has defined
such a nice set of standard
interfaces and ways
to interact to manipulate
it that I feel like the Go
community is more about
composable libraries
and composable toolkits to
build the eventual software
that you need, then
rather than building
one huge monolith of
opinionated framework.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that
is actually something
that I really
appreciated, and I'm
thinking about maybe
writing about it,
is about the power of
very simple interfaces
and how they allow you to extend
the behavior of the existing
code, right?
So if you think about
it, the ACB package
has this interface handler that
has only one method, serviceDP.
Super simple.
But that actually powers all
the other toolkits we have.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and make
that super, super powerful
it's very Unix-y, right?
You write the one
tool for one thing,
and then you pipe it to another
thing, and another thing,
and another thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Interface is like
the pipes of Go?
Yeah, why not, why not?
I could say the channels
are the pipes of Go.
Both, whatever.
But anyway, check the video to,
check the blog post, and let us
know what you think about it.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And before we leave,
I think it's
important to mention
the fact that in our
cool thing of the week,
you might have heard yesterday
a lot of cool things going on
at Google I/O. We
will be covering them
during next episode.
Until then, just you
can check the videos,
and everything is being not
open sourced, livestreamed.
MARK MANDEL: Livestreamed.
If you check the hashtag, #io16,
I'm sure there'll be plenty
of content out there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think it's going
to be hard not to find
out all the new things
before next week.
But in the meanwhile, I'm hoping
you will find them around,
and we'll cover them next week.
And next week, we'll be
talking with John [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're going to have
a interesting chat about
unikernels, which is something
up and coming.
It keeps popping
up in conversation,
so we're going to have a good,
deep conversation about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So if you're curious about
unikernels, tune in next week.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
Well, we'll definitely
be at I/O, well, now.
When this podcast is
released, right now.
Where are you going
to be after that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So by next week I
will be in Chicago
for [? Go2. ?]
And after that, I'm
going to try to relax.
Well actually, as
I said, I'm going
to be biking from
San Francisco to LA.
It's lifecycle.
But in the meanwhile,
I'm going to be preparing
my talk for July in GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And today I got a
very exciting piece
of news, which is I will be
doing the opening keynote.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I am very excited.
Kind of scary to be doing the
opening keynote at GopherCon
when one of the speakers
literally created the language.
Ralph [INAUDIBLE] will
be there, too, speaking.
MARK MANDEL: No pressure.
No pressure at all.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah, super
excited about that opportunity.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I think my big one's
coming up on June 3rd
here at the Google SF office.
We are having the
Change the Cloud summit.
So if you're interested in
building games and interacting
with the Cloud, either from
a multiplayer or possibly
an analytics perspective,
definitely sign up.
We'd love to have you come and
hang out with us for a day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thanks so much
again for taking the time
to record this
episode with me today.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
for taking the time
to record it with me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYS]